why
so as original sending comes to an end
we see the series conclude with issue
number 8 now the issue here with
original sim and one of the big
criticisms that a lot of us in the
Marvel community had is that original
sin raised just as many questions as it
answered and Marvel didn't really do a
good job of answering a lot of these
questions that cropped up what we're
also going to do here in this discussion
is we're going to for the most part
focus on Nick Fury's involvement with
regards to The Watcher we're going to
focus on what it was it took place and
we're going to learn the truth about
what happened with Nick Fury and what
happened with The Watcher when Nick Fury
arrived on the moon and what we see here
as the story opens up is a transition
into the past into a few days prior to
the current events of the original sin
event and we see that Nick Fury has
arrived after The Watcher has been
robbed and Nick Fury asked The Watcher
who it was that robbed him that how this
happened now he says that the issue here
is that the watcher is in possession of
a vast collection of weaponry a vast
collection of armament that The Watcher
sees everything and so he knows most
likely who it was that robbed him and
where they're going but that if they
take these weapons from the Watchers
armory if they take things like the
ultimate nullifier and various weapons
of Badoon origin and they fall into the
wrong hands that it could lead to total
destruction of the planet earth it could
lead to a conflict on a scale never seen
before and so he says that The Watcher
needs to explain what it is it's going
on The Watcher needs to tell him what it
was this happened what we also see here
is that Nick Fury says that because The
Watcher sees everything that is the
Watchers duty that despite the fact that
watcher doesn't necessarily involve
himself in various events all the time
that this is one event whereby the
watcher needs to take some kind of
action but the watcher simply replies by
saying that Nick Fury is correct that
the watcher does see all things even the
unseen and this is when he reveals to
make fury the fact that he can see
everything or has seen everything that
Nick
has done regarding his actions of
fighting various multi-dimensional
beings of killing various
multi-dimensional beings of killing
beings within the planet Earth and this
upsets Nick Fury this angers Nick Fury
and the reason why is because Nick Fury
tells The Watcher that he's always acted
on the side of the planet earth that
he's always fought to save the planet
Earth but that the watcher always just
watched that very rarely did he ever
actually step in and do anything despite
the fact that he had the power to stop
it that virtually any conflict that
could have arisen as a result of these
alien forces appearing had Nick Fury not
been there to stop them was something
that The Watcher could have helped with
The Watcher could have acted in such a
way to where it wasn't necessary for
Nick Fury to be the man on the wall but
instead The Watcher never did The
Watcher simply just watched and Nick
Fury is angry about this and what this
does is this gives us this dichotomy
this inherent I guess difference between
Nick Fury and The Watcher that Nick
Fury's belief system here is that it's
not enough to simply just watch it's not
enough to simply just observe there has
to be somebody that's going to actively
oppose threats and so Nick Fury views
himself as the true protector of the
earth as the one person who actually did
anything to ensure the earth was kept as
safe as possible and that The Watcher
despite the fact that he never really
did anything had the power to do it but
never did always chose not to and so for
him The Watcher is a representation of
total apathy of an individual that has
the power to stop something but chooses
not to and so what we see is that Nick
Fury again begins to shout at the
watcher Nick Fury tells the watcher who
it is or ask the watcher who it is that
stole from him about what it is it
happened here then about who it is that
he has to kill next
from here we see that again the Nick
fear Nick Fury asked the watcher why it
is they took his eye why it is that they
took the important the eyes within his
head and he says that for the most part
he searched this place over and over
again that he has looked within this
place time and time again that even when
the watcher had passed out then he had
bugged the Watchers watchtower in order
to keep an eye on him that the one thing
that he never noticed
the one thing that he never saw the
watcher doing was recording things
physically the watcher was never writing
anything down The Watcher was simply
just observing all the time and so Nick
Fury deduces that most likely all the
knowledge and everything the watcher has
ever seen is has been stored within his
eyes that the reason why one of his eyes
was taken is because it possesses a
multitude of secrets now whether or not
that eye possesses all the same secrets
as the other eye is actually a question
that Marvel doesn't answer but for the
most part because both I saw the same
thing that seems to be the case and so
that would explain why both eyes weren't
taken from the watcher from here we see
Nick Fury pointing his gun at the
watcher and again telling the watcher to
answer him telling the watcher to tell
him what it is that he saw what it is or
who it was it came in and stole his
place as all his stuff then The Watcher
simply just says that he's seen too much
that he's seen too many things and then
it's time for somebody else to watch
that it's time for somebody else to
undertake the role of the mantle of
watcher we see that The Watcher begins
to raise his hands against Nick Fury and
that he appears to be emanating some
kind of energy and that perhaps he may
be putting Nick Fury in a place where
he's going to force Nick Fury to shoot
him where he is in effect going to
commit suicide by cop but what we see as
the story continues is that we
transition back to the present day then
what we see is that the superheroes
Doctor Strange Hank Pym Emma Frost and
various other individuals have arrived
2-8 Nick Fury Ennis fight against the
mindless ones and dr. Midas who of
course are laying siege to to the
Watchers watchtower and make fury
respectively and what we see Doctor
Strange saying is that this is all going
to come to an end now that all of this
is going to end we also see that Nick
Fury says that he thinks they're here
because they've seen the truth in what
it is that he said and what it is it
needs to be done that there has to be
somebody to be the man on the wall that
he regrets the fact that he has to pass
this burden off to one of these
superheroes but somebody is going to
have to undertake this role but for him
it's a necessity it's something that
needs to be done so that the rest of the
superheroes can turn a blind eye so that
they can keep their hands clean
but so that they can also deal with
whatever is left over whatever it is the
man on the wall is not able to stop but
what we also see dr. strange saying is
that they haven't come here to redeem
Nick Fury they came here because Nick
Fury has one last cent he has to confess
to and dr. strange demands to hear it
dr. strange demands to hear what it is
that Nick Fury did to The Watcher and
Nick Fury finally after the entire
original sin event admits it Nick Fury
says that he was the one who killed the
watcher but what we see is that for the
most part it appears that the watcher
had put Nick Fury in a position where he
had no choice but to kill him that it
was either kill or be killed
that the watcher didn't really seem to
have a desire to live anymore now why it
is the watcher didn't really have a
desire to live is again something that
Marvel doesn't explain to us it's one of
these things that's left open but I
would go as far as far as to speculate
that after the events of original sin
issue number zero we had learned that
the watcher that who watched The Watcher
was looking for any reality that existed
whereby his father's actions didn't
contribute to the destruction of the the
civilization they had first encountered
had never existed that he was never able
to find this but he had for the most
part just kind of given up that he just
didn't really seem to have a reason to
live anymore and so we see that once
Nick Fury kills the watcher that Nick
Fury takes his eye from here we pick up
with Bucky Barnes confronting Nick Fury
and Bucky Barnes tells Nick Fury to
simply put the eyeball down but Nick
Fury says that that it's not finished
yet this isn't done that dr. Midas is
still within the stronghold and that
he's gaining power and that somebody
needs to stop him and that Nick Fury
thinks he's the only one who can Nick
Fury says that this is his final act
this is his final way to save the earth
his final action in the role of the man
on the wall and he hopes that Bucky
Barnes will one day recognize what it is
that he's done here that Bucky Barnes
will recognize the necessity of what it
is it has to be done here and that maybe
Bucky Barnes will be the one to
undertake the role of the man on the
wall from here we see that Nick Fury
enters the domain of the Watchers
watchtower and confronts dr. Midas and
doctor Midas appears to be absorbing
some sort of energy from the watch
from the Watchers Watchtower seems to be
emanating some sort of force now how it
is it he gains this as something we
don't really know it just simply appears
to be that he's absorbing whatever
cosmic energies have been channeled
through this place and so what we see is
that dr. Midas simply says that if Nick
Fury hands the eyes over to him then he
promises Nick Fury that he won't have to
watch what happens next that he will not
let Nick Fury see whatever it is it has
taken place now whether this is some
kind of taunt saying that he's just
going to kill Nick Fury or what we don't
really know but before we get into what
it is a doctor - actually does we end up
transitioning to the orb and what we see
is that the orb is I guess being taken
over by one of the eyes of the watcher
the Watchers eye is merging itself with
him but what we also see here is that
all these different Watchers are
watching this event take place and the
Watchers say that it's their sacred
valve that all they can do is observe
that they can't act despite the fact
that it's within their power to do so
but what we also see is that all these
other superheroes are continuing to
fight all these other superheroes are
continuing to take on the mindless ones
but for the most part they really can
they really can't understand what it is
it's going on here they really can't
fathom what it is that's taking place
here all this is this going on with
regards to dr. Midas using the Watchers
power Nick Fury's actions
the Watchers observing what's going on
and the orb I guess being taken over by
one of the eyes of the watcher it's all
way above the head of a multitude of
these superheroes and so what we see
Nick Fury doing is that again as he
transitions into the past telling us
that he had no choice that it all had to
be worth it for him that he took the
eyes of the watcher took the eye of The
Watcher under the guise that he would be
able to find who it was that had killed
the watcher had a robbed the watcher in
the first place and continued to fulfill
his role of the man on the wall and that
the Watchers I would go towards him
being able to do his job in a way that
he had never experienced before that he
would be able to see almost all the
forces that were intending to attack the
planet Earth and that he wouldn't have
to rely on investigation or the normal
means of finding who these aliens were
or the the standard practice of whatever
was a shield use for their intelligence
gathering
and so what we see is that as we
continue with this story that dr. Midas
gets the eye of the watcher plunged into
his chest as Nick Fury attempts to kill
him and for the most part it seems that
the power within the eye of the watcher
is able to totally override any power
that dr. Midas has and as the
superheroes are gathering outside of the
Watchers Watchtower they simply say that
whoever it is it comes out of this that
whoever it is it shows up after all this
is said and done that they take down
hard that they're going to ensure that
whatever it is that they're doing that
in bed it's stopped but we see that
bucky bond says that again kind of
mirroring the sentiment of Nick Fury
that they can't just stand here and
watch we see mix let me see Emma Frost
comment that whether or not Bucky Barnes
is sure about that and they look up to
see that all these different Watchers
are watching this event unfold from here
we transition back to dr. Midas and dr.
- is again being overtaken by the power
of the watcher and the Watchers eyes the
power is simply just too much for dr.
Midas's more than his body can handle
and so it appears that his body is
entirely disintegrated that his body is
totally destroyed and so as the comic as
this this begins to wind down as a comic
begins to come to a close we see that
Nick Fury is left next to the body of
the watcher and appears to have been
dying appears to in fact died from his
wounds suffered after the event of this
entire infinity storyline this entire
original sin storyline from here we
transition back to the super heroes and
the super heroes are simply gathered
around the the various parts of the
Watchers watchtower and what's the left
of it having after it had been destroyed
and Captain America simply says that
that The Watcher is dead that Nick Fury
is dead that all things all these
different things that have taken place
are going back to normal but one thing I
would like to take particular note of is
this oversight that was made I think by
the artists of original sin where Thor
is continuing to hold his hammer despite
the fact that four has previously been
seen and will actually be seen after
this being unable to wield his hammer
and this I think was actually something
that was first spotted on reddit but
what we see Captain America's saying is
that for the most part there's really
nothing left
- there's really nothing left of Nick
Fury that after Nick Fury had died that
his satellite full of the lmds had all
just disappeared that the mindless ones
have gone back to being mindless again
but for the most part everything has
gone back to the way it was before the
watcher had died before anybody had
manipulated his eyes and so for the most
part Captain America has no idea what it
is is going on here he doesn't know what
drove Nick Fury to act this way and he
asked Doctor Strange and black panther
if they may know for the most part what
we see here is that Doctor Strange asked
Black Panther why it is that he didn't
tell Captain America what it is that he
knew and black panther says he never
tells anyone anything and he asked
Doctor Strange why he didn't tell him
and Doctor Strange says that maybe he
will one day that after this is all said
and done maybe he'll tell Captain
America about what's going on but that
after the eyes were used against the
superheroes after their secrets were
revealed to each other that for the most
part nobody trusts anybody and that
they've all become even more secretive
than they were before and that maybe
this secret whatever it is should die
with Nick Fury that Nick Fury is
presumably dead and that all these
things have finally come to a close but
what we see is that there's some
individual that's cloaked that is
wrapped in a cowl of some kind that's
simply just standing behind dr. strange
and black panther in a very eerie sort
of way and what we get is this this bit
of information or I guess the sort of
epilogue telling us what's happened
after very after the original sin event
had come to an end at this point we
transitioned back to some sort of alien
forces that are discussing the fact that
The Watcher has been killed that various
superhero groups are in shambles and
that now is the time for these
superheroes or for the planet earth to
be conquered and for their forces to
invade but before they're able to get
too far one of his one of them is shot
in the face and we see that Bucky Barnes
the Winter Soldier has undertaken the
role of the man on the wall and this as
Marvel has explained it to us is the
precursor to the Bucky Barnes Winter
Soldier solo series we're going to
follow Bucky Barnes as he is part of the
as he is the man on the
wall and it's actually something that
I'm extremely excited about to see what
it does it happens and how his character
plays out from here we see that as
Marvel completely brings the original
sin event to an end as we get to the
very end of this comic that Marvel tells
us that things are winding down that
things are beginning to come to an end
that all these secrets that all these
sins are for the most part beginning to
come to a close and that there is an
individual there is a man that stands on
the moon and that his job is to forever
watch for eternity to watch but never
interfere to always be unseen and what
we see is that this man is Nick Fury
that Nick Fury is still alive but seems
to be chained to the to the moon seems
to be chained and stuck to the moon so
that he can never leave and so that for
the rest of eternity he will simply just
monitor he will simply just watch the
planet Earth and that he will never ever
be able to be allowed to interfere that
he'll never be able to undertake the
role of being the man on the wall with
that being said we're going to go ahead
and bring an event or bring to bring it
into the original sin event I really
hope you guys enjoyed it if you did let
me know and I will catch you guys later
peace
you